the whole country will rejoice at this
news and will share in relief that their
horrendous ordeal is over
nazanin was held in iran for almost six
years and anushay almost five
murad has been imprisoned for four
their release is the result of years of
tenacious british diplomacy
i want to thank our romani friends and
minister bader
for their help in bringing our nationals
home
and i pay tribute to the efforts of many
in this house particularly the members
for hampstead and kilburn and lewisham
east
i pay tribute as well to my predecessors
and my right honourable friend the prime
minister who have all worked hard to
resolve this issue
but most of all i want to express my
admiration for the incredible resolve
and determination shown by nazanin
anushay morad and their families
i have been in contact with them
throughout together with our specialist
consular teams
their suffering has moved us all and so
does the prospect of them being reunited
with their loved ones once again after
this long and cruel separation
we secured the release a murad's
furlough through intense diplomatic and
political engagement at every level
and we've stepped up these efforts over
the last six months
on becoming foreign secretary in
september i made resolving the continued
detention of british nationals and the
ims debt personal priorities
in my first week i spoke to the families
of the detainees and met my iranian
counterpart minister abdullian
this was the first in-person meeting of
a uk and iranian foreign minister for
three years
we agreed to work together to resolve
these two issues in parallel
i dispatched a team of foreign office
negotiators to hold intensive
discussions with senior iranian
officials to secure the release of our
detainees
officials traveled to tehran for
negotiations in october and november a
final round of negotiations took place
in muscat in february resulting in this
agreement
our ambassador in tehran simon shercliff
has also been in constant talks with
iranian ministers and senior officials
and i spoke to minister abdullian in
october to progress the talks
in december i met minister bader and i
secured amman's assistance in this
important work and in february i held
discussions with minister abdullian
again to drive the talks to a final
conclusion
we will continue to push with partners
to secure morad's permanent release home
which is long overdue and we will
continue to support other british
nationals in iran who have asked for our
help
we will work closely with our
international partners to urge iran to
end its practice of unfair detention it
remains and always has been within
iran's gift to release any british
national who's been unfairly detained
the agonies endured by nazanin anushay
murad and their families must never
happen again
our efforts to settle the imf debt have
also reached their conclusion
after highly complex and exhaustive
negotiations the more than 40-year-old
debt between the international military
services and the ministry of defense of
iran has now been settled
as the house is aware this debt relates
to contracts signed with the iranian
ministry of defence in the 1970s
following the revolution of 1979 these
contracts could not be fulfilled
i pushed officials to be as creative as
possible in finding a way to resolve
this situation and they have worked
round the clock to find a viable payment
route
we have considered and exhausted many
options in the process
but i can tell the house
we have found a way to make the payment
in full
in compliance with uk and international
sanctions and global counter-terrorism
financing and anti-money laundering
regulations
a sum of
393.8 million pounds has now been paid
which will only be available for
humanitarian purposes
the terms remain confidential to both
parties
we have long said we would find a
solution to the ims debt
now thanks to the tireless work of our
officials we have found a way to do so
the repayment of the debt
in parallel with the release of our
nationals reflects steps taken by both
the uk and iran to resolve issues of
serious disagreement between our two
countries
we will continue to stand up for our
interests for the freedom and security
of our nationals wherever they are
and for an end to arbitrary detention
but for now to nazanin and anushay
i am pleased that in just a few hours
time we will be able to say welcome home
i commend this statement to the house
[Applause]
[Music]